Thanos' adopted daughter is the highlight
of almost every Guardians of the Galaxy story
she appears in, but if you only know Gamora
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe, you're
missing out.
She's much more than a world-class assassin.
She's also a time traveler, a mother, a fashion
icon, and a lover... and she's wielded one
of the most powerful weapons ever made.
Gamora's comic backstory is full of twists
and turns that are crazy in all the best ways.
There's a reason Gamora is called "the most
dangerous woman in the universe."
Let's take a look at some of the story elements
you might not know about Marvel's green superheroine.
Unfortunate origin
In the MCU, Gamora's origin is pretty straightforward.
Her planet was wiped out by Thanos, who rescued
her and raised her to be a warrior.
She eventually turned on Thanos, teamed up
with Star-Lord, Rocket, Drax, and Groot, and
the rest is history.
In the comics, Gamora first appeared in Strange
Tales #180, but we don't learn her history
until Warlock #10.
As the story goes, Thanos correctly predicted
that the villainous Magus, a time-warped version
of hero Adam Warlock and leader of the tyrannical
Universal Church of Truth, threatened his
plans for galactic domination.
So, Thanos needed a weapon he could use to
stop Magus before he grew too powerful.
He found one, in the future.
Years after Warlock #10 takes place, Magus'
soldiers killed Gamora's kinsfolk, the pacifist
Zen Whoberis as part of their crusade.
Thanos, however, managed to rescue Gamora
at the last minute, took her to the present,
and trained her to stop Magus once and for
all.
Her assassination attempt fails, and Gamora
flat-out perishes after turning on Thanos,
but she still helps Adam Warlock beat Magus
and the Church anyway.
Unseen action
Like her origin story, Gamora's earliest days
are pretty confusing.
After two appearances in Strange Tales, her
story moves into the Warlock standalone series.
Then, the struggle between Thanos, Adam, and
Gamora concludes in Avengers Annual #7 and
Marvel Two-in-One Annual #2.
As a result of all of this ping-ponging between
different books, there's one big hole: while
Gamora eventually learns about Thanos' true
nature and betrays him, we never actually
see the whole story.
In Warlock #15, Gamora is tasked by Thanos
to hunt down Adam Warlock, but is attacked
en route by Drax… but then the series ends.
Next we see her, she's been left for dead
by Thanos himself.
So, what happened?
Seeing Gamora betray her surrogate father
should've been a real big moment, but it was
reduced to three flashback panels.
According to author Jim Starlin, Warlock was
ultimately cancelled due to poor sales, so
he had limited pages to wrap the story up,
which meant supporting characters like Gamora
got the short end of the stick, leaving her
epic family drama as a footnote.
Nine lives
Gamora might be good at taking lives, but
that doesn't mean she hasn't lost her own
a time or two.
When she was a kid, she snuck out against
Thanos' wishes on the planet Tartoonla #7
and got attacked and slaughtered a by a roving
street gang.
Thanos had to rebuild her from artificial
parts, and she lost her tear ducts in the
deal.
We also see Gamora die in Avengers Annual
#7, and while her body perishes, her soul
is saved by Adam Warlock, but her spirit,
along with Warlock's and Pip the Troll's,
ended up safely ensconced inside the Soul
Gem, one of the Infinity Stones.
She returns to life in Infinity Gauntlet #1,
published about 14 years later, but there's
a catch: her soul is put into the corpse of
a woman named Bambi Long.
Even when Gamora is alive, she's still technically
not.
When Thanos uses the Infinity Gauntlet to
end half of the life in the universe, Gamora
bites it again, although Nebula resurrects
her and everyone else.
In other words, Gamora might be one of the
strongest heroes in the universe, but her
life tends to come and go.
Gem carrier
So far, Marvel's movies have been all about
the Infinity Stones, six brightly colored
and infinitely powerful rocks that act as
the MacGuffins for the entire MCU.
The Red Skull used one to fuel his superweapons.
Loki's scepter held the Mind Stone, which
later ended up bringing the Vision to life.
The Reality Stone pops up in Thor: The Dark
World, the Time Stone plays a crucial role
in Doctor Strange, and the Power Stone is
the thing that drives the action in Guardians
of the Galaxy.
The Infinity Gems have comic book counterparts,
of course, although on the printed page they're
better known as the Soul or Infinity Gems.
They've been around since 1972, and they play
a big role in Infinity Gauntlet, which is
a foundation for Avengers: Infinity War.
It's not just Thanos that's wielded the gems,
however.
After Infinity Gauntlet, Adam Warlock took
control of the Infinity Gems, but higher powers
than him decided that it was too much power
for one person to handle, and distributed
the gems among some of Marvel's cosmic heroes,
including Gamora.
As part of the superteam known as Infinity
Watch, Gamora was entrusted with guarding
the Time Gem.
Now, Gamora didn't actually know how to use
the Time Gem, although she'd occasionally
get prophetic visions thanks to the gem's
influence, and she eventually gave up her
duties and left the Watch.
The gems were stolen and Infinity Watch disbanded
shortly thereafter.
Mommy dearest
By now, you might've noticed that Adam Warlock
plays a big part in Gamora's pre-Guardians
life.
Given the laws of comic book relationships,
that means that they'll inevitably hook up.
Warlock and Gamora didn't just become a couple,
however, they actually have a child together,
albeit an adopted one.
In Infinity Abyss, Jim Starlin's 2002 entry
in his long-running "Infinity Saga," five
clones of Thanos called the Thanosi set out
to kill Thanos and destroy the universe.
Naturally, Warlock, Gamora, and their friends
try to stop them.
The key to the Thanosi's scheme is an all-powerful
being called Atlez, the "anchor of reality"
since the days of the Roman Empire.
When Atlez realizes his time is running out,
he realizes he needs to pass on his knowledge
to a human girl named Atleza, who was born
for this purpose.
There's just one problem: Atleza is still
a little girl.
Gamora and her buddies end up defeating the
Thanosi, but Atleza, who's kinda overwhelmed
with her newfound cosmic powers, needs training.
As such, Gamora and Warlock retire to a pocket
dimension to teach her the ways of the universe
while also serving as her foster parents.
It's one of the weirdest families imaginable,
but for Warlock and Gamora, weird is an everyday
thing.
With the two of them at her side, Atleza should
be just fine.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!